if you look too long in one direction
you might be faced with an ejection
yeah staring is now a social blunder in
the land down under
club 77 nightclub in sydney australia
named after the number of women will
kane once made out with one night
[Laughter]
club 77
has banned staring staring without
explicit verbal consent
from the person you want to stare at i
hope you're consenting right now
now it doesn't take an expert to realize
that the locking eyes across the room
move might not work as well if you start
with shouting i would like to stare at
you is that cool
[Laughter]
are we good
all right now we're good
that couldn't be creepier unless you
were wearing a trench coat
and named jeffrey toobin
and sure this might work in australia i
mean they do box kangaroos after all
down under
but in america bars are made for
socializing
take it from me
it's where i met my fourth fifth and
seventh wives
[Laughter]
anyway at the club safety officers
wearing pink vests will be there to
enforce the staring room not kidding
but the owners also warned that a
failure to adhere
to those policies might even result in a
call to the police
according to the telegraph the british
paper not the 19th century messaging
device
the bar does want people to interact
with strangers it just requires that any
engagement must begin with verbal
consent
for more let's go live outside the bar
to our new australian correspondent
boomerang bailey boom what's the latest
yeah g'day pete tonight i've set out to
answer the question who's it really
hurting if you stare while you're
flirting in fact we've got some
nightclub goers right now excuse me miss
did this wide-eyed bloke get you both
kicked out worth it he's so hot
you're right and you don't care that
he's staring
absolutely not whatever looking at you
so high
sir do you care to comment
[Music]
okay so you don't know this guy he could
be a serial killer but you don't care i
told you i don't care he's hot whatever
i gotta go
right good on you then uh
well pete i guess the only rule here is
be hot shouldn't be a problem for you
mate
back to you
well done well done
uh
cat as our as the i think the unofficial
nightclub correspondent of the gutfeld
show i don't go to the club
there's nothing you did you just told me
a story as we're waiting to come out
here about not getting into a club oh
yeah that was a long i'm married
[Laughter]
i'm married now so there's two before me
there you go i go to gay gay bars but
not like straight ones i would imagine
staring at nobody at a gay bar staring
at me so fair point so that probably
makes you feel more comfortable now does
staring make you make you uncomfortable
at bars or clubs
i guess but i i don't really like yes
like having a creepy dude stare at you
it sucks but i've i guess i've just had
bigger problems than that
i'm trying to think like you know like i
am a really good looking so obviously
people stare
so you know intellectual that i don't
let it bother me that much
[Applause]
it's about what's in here not what's
here
i got you i got you well this is the
only tactic many men have is the stare
down
the stair down yeah the look look again
eyes eyes what if if you don't have it
you're basically unarmed how long do we
have this segment because i have a lot
please
the only thing more creepy than me
staring directly at you for a long
period of time would be me going up to
you and going do you mind if i stare at
it yeah
like that is
really creepy
um and what about the poor guy as i
think well acted in our piece there what
about the guy has like walleye or
something you know he just kind of can't
help it this is the way he looks and
then some pink police officer says quit
staring he's like i didn't stare now he
has an ada claim
no this is a lot he might have an ada
claim yes
by the way why is an island of of former
ex-cons
australia the one that wants to like now
run everybody's life they they all want
to be the prison guard oh from provide
to nightclubs
offensive to me as a woman like if
someone's staring at me that's going to
bother me so much you need to call the
cops like i can handle it yes
michael have you ever been allowed
inside a nightclub
no
one time though i did get naked and i
got on a wrecking ball and just swung
through the seat
that was the miley cyrus i see that but
did you stare at anyone uh of course
listen uh this rule really it does only
affect ugly people right
so like
like like all the sexual harassment laws
it's only if it's someone like yeah
and i'm completely disappointed in
australia as well
like they've they're losing their street
cred like we've lost our cowboy street
cred as americans in australia they
should be just like getting crazy
drinking whiskey and steering right at
you
and then here's the thing so if i if i'm
caught staring at someone and then they
report me and someone gets to come can't
you just deny that it was you and as
they're looking at you accuse them of
staring true yeah right take that you
pink double stare
and i guess they're also going to outlaw
there's something on your shirt and then
you flick them in the nose
they're going to they're not going to
outlaw wedgies
there's no fun in australia no more mate
you are bringing our cowboy swagger back
with that shirt though yes i appreciate
that trying to you're doing well i'm
transitioning to cowboy
well played sir well played
kaylee uh is any of this normal no
[Laughter]
no this is a good question
i have so much in the 21st century the
answer is no um this isn't starbucks
this is in an ice cream store like you
get what you sign up for and staring is
a part of going to a club michael loftus
your theory is not going to work on how
you're going to handle your staring
accusation because i will tell you this
is now part of the policy we adopt a
policy of always believing the report in
the case of harassment they will always
believe the staring accuser and not the
accused and this isn't due process and
i'll leave it at that but nobody ever
believes michael officers
michael just switch roles that sounds
like just become the accuser on someone
else that sounds like the australian
equivalent of uh believe all women yes
it's probably going to be women accusing
men everybody goes to clubs to make sure
they're not looked at yeah that's
exactly why you didn't know why you were
going 2 o'clock yeah all right we solved
it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else